foreign
my name is Dr Cotter
I'm a therapist do you want to sit down
I know you're nervous
that's okay
I just want to have a chat
I promise this is a safe place
not for me
why do you say that
come on
let's sit
please
foreign
I'm gonna have to ask you a couple of
questions that might sound stupid
what
day of the week is it
Thursday
and the month October I'm not crazy
nobody's saying that no but I need you
to understand I'm a PhD candidate I'm
not some lunatic okay
take a breath and you could just tell me
what's going on
I'm seeing something
no one else can see except for me
I know how insane that sounds I do but
it's
this thing I can't explain it
what is it you're seeing
it looks like people
but it's not a person
I'm not sure I understand it looks like
people it looks like different people
sometimes it pretends to be someone that
I know sometimes it's a random stranger
sometimes
sometimes it looks like my grandfather
who died in front of me when I was seven
but it's all the same thing and
it's
it's like
it's like it wears people's faces like
like masks
do you see it right now here
what happens when you do see it
smiling at me
but not a friendly smile it's the worst
smile I've ever seen in my life and
whenever I see it I just get this
god-awful feeling like something really
terrible
happened
I've never felt scared like I do when I
see
Laura have you or anyone else in your
family ever experienced hallucinations
it's not an hallucination no it's real
you don't get it it does things to me it
calls to happen around me
it's taking over my whole life and my
mind and
tells me things
it told me that today today's the
today's the day that I'm I'm gonna okay
that's okay
foreign
I know that what you're experiencing
feels incredibly real
sometimes when we get emotionally
overwhelmed or experience an intense
trauma our minds you're not listening to
me oh my God
Laura
can you look at me please
laughs
look at me
[Music]
hey it's okay it's just us there's
nobody else here
I I have a patient emergency email too I
need staff here now hurry
Laura
foreign
[Music]